opening the hearing
on House Bill
he hearing or subcommittee work
session thank you sub committee work
session thank you representative
mchu I'd like to recognize
representative Darby to present his
Amendment that's amendment
number number it is
22968 uh thank you chair um yes so um
you know we're a little bit of History
here um there were two bills that were
um that were that had a lot in common
last uh last year 205 and 398 205 had a
section on well testing for new wells um
as well as notification in um in
purchase and sales agreements 398 had um
a similar notification in purchase and
sales agreements as well as a disclosure
on the um in the the um real estate
disclosure forms um and uh what the
committee decided to do at the time was
take 205 to the floor with I recall a
slight Amendment um and uh hold back 398
um uh 205 was tabled and uh died on the
table um and 398 was um as I mentioned
it had the um it had an a a notification
in the purchase and sale as well as the
disclosure talking to the prime sponsor
um the disclosure uh uh which was the
most problematic portion of 398 because
it talked about um a notice that goes to
um by Dees to um to people with property
within 500 feet I think it's 500 feet um
of um of a well that's been that has
tested with pasas um there my
recollection um is the dees was a bit
uncomfortable with that language and um
and my understanding to speaking with
the prime sponsors that wasn't really
the intent that wasn't the focus of the
bill um there's also been some
discussions with um the Realtors as well
as the um Dees on determining what
language
um is meets the intent of 398 this past
notification intent um at while not um
while retaining the portions of the
existing notifications that are
important to many people across the
state as an example um one of the things
that the the notification in 205 tried
to change was really dramatically change
the the notification to talk about
testing in general of wellwater and some
members of this um of the broader uh
resources uh committee um were concerned
about the removal of the specific
arsonic Clause from that taking this
input having discussed with um Dees the
prime sponsor um the Realtors through
their representative um we uh that
that's that was the so of the derivation
of this amendment which as you see is um
very similar to the existing
notifications with a past Clause the
past Clause um is I honestly can't
remember the exact um uh pedigree of it
you know what the exact source of this
was but it takes into account portion um
language from 205 language from 398 it
was um vetted um feel free we can ask
you but I did run it by Dees and uh got
some some some wording changes on it
which is what you see here and I also
sent this previously um twice with two
different versions to the Realtors as
far as I know um the the parties
involved so that's the dees the Realtors
um and the prime sponsor are comfortable
with the language that we have here and
that's that's where this uh Amendment
comes from
thanks thank you representative Darby it
sounds like a a lot of work has gone
into the amendment um I'd like to
recognize representative Healey to
present some information that he brought
in before the
hearing yeah um the only thing that I
would want to add on this is at the end
of that statement provide is or provide
test results for the well testing within
the last three years because if they've
already tested their Wells and they're
giving that information they already
have
it Go representative
Darby um so this um just to be clear
this is not the disclosure this is just
the notification that says we suggest
that you test through well there there's
no requirement for this there's no
there's no action required this is
basically the the goal if I understand
from the prime sponsor perspective and
definitely my personal goal is um pasas
awareness um P or uh past has been
detected in I'll use the word unhealthy
levels thees has slightly different
language um throughout the state
particularly in Southern New Hampshire
um a lot of people don't know that it's
in their well water today um they do
know because of disclosures and other um
uh I'd say other um advertising me that
um Wells can contain radon and Arsenic
and lead and things that can be tested
and are fre commonly tested for the
purpose of this is to to say um past
does exist in a lot of places and to be
safe you should test but there is no
mandate at all and there's no
requirement and so that's why um I
definitely you know I I'd like to hear
what the other stakeholders say about
that but I I'm not sure about the the
need for an action in in terms of the
notification I'm not talking about the
action if they I'm just saying if they
have the test that they should come
forward with that test the is testing
all over the southern part of the state
if they've tested my well when they're
so in the house if you want you should
come forward
if representative
G yes I'm having my water tested for the
second time by St gain but anyway uh so
far I've been okay but if I were to buy
a house you know sometimes you say I'm I
want to have the house what is that
thing inspected by the inspectors and
sometimes you make a deal with the
people who are selling the house to have
that done who pays for it Etc I I would
think that with your concern couldn't
you make a deal with the realtor to say
test for pfas or all these things and do
that as part of your you know mandate he
doesn't want to make it a mandate and I
agree with no mandate I mean but this no
this wouldn't be a mandate because you
don't have to have your house inspected
either but you're buying as you know
it's the same idea it's just gee maybe
I'll make that part of the
negotiations you know so it's up to the
person to figure out all these things I
guess because some people might not want
to pay for it but that's not mandatory
and it's just letting them know that
they might want to get it done somehow
that's just my
thought thank you for that um input I'm
going to recognize representative
mchu thank you madam chair represent
Derby thanks for the work on this this
is this is great after collaborating on
205 oh by the way I I don't think it's
actually dead on the table I think it's
still on the table so we it's laate on
the table so I think technically we
could bring it off the table as a as a
full body couldn't we uh it wouldn't be
I mean it' be difficult but I think it's
possible is it maybe it takes it twoth
thirs so it's on so it's not dead yet
just I
mean you're right it's good but it will
be in a minute no I'm just kidding sorry
if you're Monty Python fan you might get
that a very obscure reference um
represent of Healey the
um the and we ghou also the a disclosure
of test results I fundamentally agree
with but they can do it already so I
don't know if we need to put it in here
and they can you can also have your
water tested as part of an inspection
like you could have your septic tested
or anything else so my preference
probably would be go with this amendment
and and just leave it off mainly so we
don't have to redraft another amendment
and it's already possible and we don't
want it to get construed as something
more than it is um this just adds a nice
clear um passage which is similar to
what I think is on DS website if not
identical um I'd be curious to hear from
DS2 just to confirm but I think it's
identical so the Realtors are probably
okay with it it's just like the list of
things that that we add yeah so ad them
yeah okay um so just adds to the list
and it's good good public policy
especially for those of us down where
all the red dots
are so um can we hear from the prime
sponsor to whoever believe is here
absolutely what I from gallery or what I
thought I would do is go around the room
and everyone on the subcommittee if they
want or not or who's just present as far
as represent resentatives go and then
we'll call people people up to um answer
our
questions representative Rulo did you
want to weigh
in thank you I know I'm over here uh the
only thing I want to I want to wait
until I hear from everyone else that I
want to find out what exactly is the
ramifications of this what are what's
what exists now what changes might have
to be
made and how it
affects the realtor and the uh uh and
the
administration I think I think you did
but I want to hear from them too
so thank you representative Rulo
representative wolf do you have comments
that you would like to add before
we
I don't have pink card so I think I want
to do is call up the prime sponsor
representative Thomas representative
Thomas um if you want to have a seat and
we'll thank you have some questions
answered thank you madam chair um I have
worked with representative Derby on this
and in I agree with it I would have
liked to have seen T in be mandatory but
I will settle for this which is just
um awareness of pasas which I think is
the is really important and is a good
step you know I I agree with this three
minor minor things about the amendment I
don't even think it's enough to hold it
back on line nine um the addition and
past um I would just put chemicals after
that to um to drive home the point that
we're not talking about substance well
we're not talking about um products like
gortex or anything like that we're
talking about pfast
chemicals um in line 32 just to be
consistent instead of substances I would
also put
chemicals because again we're talking
about the chemicals and not necessarily
um substances in on page two on line
five just I used to be a tech writer for
digital Equipment Corporation passive
versus active the Laboratories measure
past levels it's not that they can
measure again that's a that's a really
minor editorial thing um and with regard
to the the previous testing point that
representative Healey made um I will use
our well as an example we tested our
well in
2016 the levels were high enough that we
had to shut our well down we could no
longer use the water for drinking we had
it retested in 2021 and the results were
incredibly higher so had we stopped at
2016 and used those testing results for
the sale of our house it would have
indicated a far lower level than what
was actually there so um that's just
something to be aware
of thank you
representative other members have
questions for representative Thomas
representative M thank you madam chair
good morning representative Thomas um so
fundamentally you're okay with this with
possibly fixing
the I'm I'm actually not sure about line
five uh on page two because I think it
implies that the the possibility of
measuring that they might not always be
able to measure I think that's why it's
the can we could change it to could also
a writer so I get it's not a hill I'm
going to die on it's a net well do you
think it makes is it impactful enough to
change it I'm fussy about this language
too no it's it's it's passive versus
active and it still gets the point
across so yeah I would not hold up
anything for that at all and as far as
the general further question thank you
please go ahead thanks for just having a
dialogue um the uh as far as the the
generally accepted usage of these terms
using chemicals versus substances that
actually does sound fairly important
what do you what's your opinion on
this well and again because um as you
know from March um uh past substances
could include clothing carpet it yeah
right so this would just we're focusing
on the actual chemicals um and right now
in New Hampshire we only measure for
pest chemicals so um is that important
to put in here I know I've had blood
work where I've had had 40 past
chemicals measured in my blood so are we
are we going to state that only the four
that we measure in New Hampshire are are
enough for this or are we going to just
leave it as a pfast
panel mean since it's since it's
fundamentally a notification which we're
trying as good public policy trying to
encourage people go figure out if you
have contaminants or
not maybe substances is
it's not so bad
um I know I would ask the questions like
what about the carpet or the awning or I
don't know you know pick pick something
else um representative mchu my
understanding is that those things get
detected um one of the things that we're
discovering now is that the pumps and
Wells contain past themselves and those
break down over time so we really want
to just name those substances and I
think there a really you know I am
absolutely on board with having um a
statement
that
includes exactly what you were talking
about and so that we have all of the
past chemicals I don't think we need to
delineate them here but I think that's a
good question for people that are
working with the policy every day as
well representative
Darby thank you madam chair um I I'm
very um I'm not comfortable with
changing the word substances if we look
at the EPA past site it says per it says
exactly what's after the colon poly and
per it says per and poly FL flu alkaline
substances P if you look at the dees
site for pasas um welcome to the uh Dees
past response website it says per and
poly floral alkaline substances pasas
like this is this is the language
exactly on the dees I'm not sure we want
to come up with a different term person
that that's what we were hoping to find
out I think that's
great that's a very good argument and if
that's if that's the case then I would
simply suggest on line nine you have
past
substances just to identify again it's
not a killer you know it's it's just
it's the tech writer in me that's trying
to um make things as clear as possible
so what you're saying representative um
is that on line nine we would put
chemicals no I'm saying now on line 32
keep substances if that's the way it's
used at the EPA and Dees I'm fine with
that however to make it um match on line
nine I would use past
substances so just to make it clear
I'm just going to acknowledge that
representative rang is here and I want
to ask if you know when we came in
representative rung what we did was went
around the room and people started
talking about where we're starting in
terms of legislators with working on
this bill um and representative Thomas
has just come up and we've just started
asking some
questions any comments or contributions
about the amendment or I just I just
have one one
concern I don't want to get
beyond the what we do now as far as
testing I mean every now and then every
now and then all the time we're having
bills come in here about testing uh for
PES that are not part of the list that
know the the big four that we that we
actually are in statute or that are in
that we we test for and I don't want
this to be construed at all as requiring
that we start testing for stuff that out
without having gone through the proper
uh proper uh channels I don't I don't
want to go big beyond what we do now
don't want to put inadvertently put that
into into
statute um so for coming from my
clarification um what you're saying is
that you don't want a testing
mandate well yeah well that's that's
something else yes this is not a mandate
this is just a notification of people
people that hey folks it's out there and
we consider yourself
warned and that's it exactly is that
what that that's the intent of this uh
of this uh Amendment uh yeah yes it that
is the intent of the amendment and um
when we think about this bill came into
to us with as this came in as a
notification bill but when we were
working on 205 we we tabled that bill um
and we did that because we wanted to
just pull it back to a notification and
wait for some of the language that's
going to be coming forward from the
federal and from Dees to to make sure
that we're syncing up and doing the
right thing at the right time right also
I don't want to uh want to interfere
with the people's right of
contract that uh if if you are as a
seller say I'm selling this as
is it is now and you as the purchaser to
understand that we put your big boy
pants on and get your job get it done uh
you know we all this we're not going to
be I don't want to don't want to change
that contractual uh uh uh
Dynamic that exists
now so I just want to comment to that to
say that yes we want that notification
to be out there we want that person
who's purchasing the home to feel that
they're being warned and that is really
the only intent that we're working on
right now in terms of amending the
bill representative M um I'll defer to
representative dar but happy to move
move this amendment and well is that is
anybody
else
sureair I was just going to say that um
and this is in response to
representative Renzo's um comment about
measuring just the big four um because I
had blood work done and 40 chemicals
were were isolated 12 are over the the
toxic limit that's allowed for humans my
doctors took that information and
because of it I had medical treatment
based on that so this this doesn't have
to do with a house but what I'm I'm just
saying be careful to of limiting and
it's not in this bill but in the future
limiting to just those four because
there's more out there there's a lot
more out there and they're doing damage
so that's all that's it was just a
statement not a
question and it's an important statement
because as we go forward you know this
is why this is taking time and that we
have to go through this and make sure
that we're doing incremental steps that
bring us all we can't afford to not all
go in the same direction right now with
pasas um there are more than four
chemicals and that is relevant
information to people um we don't want
to think that certain past chemicals are
there is no good
P there is no good amount of it and it
is just a nightmare to try to manage
what's going on here so thank you so
much and for indulging our questions do
representative have any more questions
for representative
Thomas we can call you back up if we
need to thank
you thank
you
would you like to come
forward good
morning your mic sorry right good
morning I'm Brandon kernin I'm the
administrator of the drinking water and
groundwater Bureau at
Dees and yes I've worked with
representative derby um on on this bill
and I think it's very important um p is
a big issue Statewide in Southern New
Hampshire it's just unfathomable the the
issues that we're dealing with in
Southern New Hampshire so you know short
of having money and resources which
we're pursuing from responsible parties
to test every well and let people know
what they have and help to mitigate
exposure this is one more positive step
we can take until we get there to let
people know about past and educate them
and help them know it's important to
test their well U I think the language
as it is is pretty good
we have well it is good we have mcls or
maximum containment levels for Four Past
compounds in New Hampshire um but this
December EPA is going to finalize its
Federal mcls which will apply at least
to our water systems but we will use
them and Outreach to private o owners
for at least six it'll include the four
we currently have standards for although
their standards will be lower from
everything I hear but it also have pfbs
and Gen X so I think what's important to
do to complement this build bills at
Dees update um a brochure a fact sheet
for the general public that can
complement this bill that we can give to
Laboratories can be readily found on our
website to let them know about the
testing options you can test what we
regulate for you can test what Dees
usually tests for the 29 compounds um we
can list things Beyond just our
standards new federal standards but also
the federal advisories there's another
level of guidance that's out there and
try to put that in a really simplistic
way so homeowner can understand their
testing options and uh you know this was
a cost difference as you increase with
more compounds but they know what
they'll get for that cost and they'll
have numbers to compare it to based on
federal advisories and standards and
state standards and advisories so I
think this is very helpful and I thank
you for your work on
this thank you so much representative
Darby can you comment on um the
suggestion of um changing the um the
title of the chapter um
44 uh 4774 a from an past to and past
substances do you have a comment on that
perhaps just spelling it out as we have
in line 32 because the S and pest is
substances so maybe if you just spell it
out you kind of kill two words with one
stone you say what it is and you have
the word substances
there
representative mchu sorry I'm thick so
no need to change it then in 30 in in
nine because it's spelled out 32 in one
other place I think maybe just 32 so do
we need do we need to redraft an
amendment in the middle of os busy
season to add that one word or is it
sufficient where it is in 32 I'm
indifferent on it I'm just thinking for
efficiency so we can get get this
approved by the
subcommittee I have no doubt that past
will get a lay person to where they need
to be to understand what it is if you
Google p and drinking water you'll have
a gold mind of information
great additional thoughts from
anyone representative rang yeah thank
you madam chair and I'm I apologize for
being
late and I don't know how much of this
was discussed before I came but I want
to make a couple points one is earlier
this year the EPA issued new health
advisories for p and I think it was just
for pfoa and Mr ker maybe you can
correct me if I'm wrong but it
essentially said there is no safe levels
that even in the parts per quadrillion
level poses a health issue so I know
that in the um the bill that we have um
I don't have the line numbers but when
it says that PS occurs in is common
groundwater contamination in New
Hampshire that occurs at unhealthy
levels I think we need to strike that
because any level is unhealthy and um
also um you know we tend to focus on
those areas of the state that have been
Hotspots for uh past contamination but
earlier this year um oh thank you very
much changed a little
bit levels that exceed oh okay no that
sounds good thank you um but the other
thing I'm not sure this committee is
aware but there was a soil study that
was done jointly with the US Geological
Survey and I believe Dees was involved
in that where they took the state of New
Hampshire and they divided it into a
grid of a 100 so essentially I mean
there were some spots I couldn't cover
but essentially it was just a grid of a
hundred and they found pasas in every
single soil sample so we know from our
experience not just in miramac but in
other parts of the country that when
pasas is in soil it ends up being in
groundwater or it's likely in
groundwater because it leeches through
the soil and so I think we it is safe to
assume that in all areas of the state
there's going to be p in the
groundwater um and if it's not there
already it's coming and so many people
particularly those people in the North
Country rely on Wells for their drinking
water that um I think it's really really
important to make sure that notification
is in place to alert them that you could
have you may not have an industrial area
in your in your community but it's
likely you've gotten pasts that have
come from somewhere else landed on the
soil and got into the well water and
that there is no safe level of pasas so
if they have that notification then they
would have they would be better informed
to make the choice of water uh treatment
to to remove the pasas so many people in
Southern New Hampshire and I know our
our chairman Rulo has a treatment but
you know it gives people the information
to be able to make an informed decision
about how what type of treatment they
would need to do for their well water
because many treatments that people have
now for well water maybe it's to REM
remove iron or manganese um AR snic
those are things the treatment for those
um um atoms don't treat don't remove
pasas there's specific ways to remove
pasas that won't work um if you're
removing
minerals so I just wanted to make that
and thank you very much representative
Darby for sharing the amendment with me
representative Rulo just
one one uh one qu one concern uh what
what we're doing here is just putting
together a a a notification to be handed
to the
people uh not to dig down into all of
the the the issues of
how you treat and things like that that
Tak can that but this is just a trigger
mechanism and we is we all agree on that
uh and also who does what uh all I read
here it says prior to execution of any
contract uh there this you have to have
a a uh a
notification uh okay I think are you
going to answer that okay that's I'll
I'll shut
up thank you madam chair so I have the
um pns statement that the uh realtor
sent us when we talked about 398 and you
can see I mean I don't didn't print it
out unfortunately but you can see that
the three paragraphs that pre that
already exist radon arsenic lead those
are verbatim in that five-page pns
statement and so this is going to be and
the pns statement is what the um Mr
Schmidt can correct me but what goes to
you know the the potential buyer y
basically when at least in my cases in
the past when you when you put your
deposit down like here or actually when
I think the realtor even gives it to you
when you're looking like here's the
here's the notifications and so this
basically says like hey these are the
things you ought to be thinking about
when you're going to buy this house it's
it's just the notification it's not the
disclosures when you're when you're um
at the when you're signing on the dotted
line at the at the um during the
transaction and in fact other portions
of this of the existing language of the
bill right um of the law I just read it
to you paragraph two because we're only
modifying paragraph one paragraph two
states nothing in this section shall be
construed to have any impact on the
legal validity of title transferred
pursuant to the purchase and sale
contract so this is just like hey you
you got to be aware of this thing and
it's and it's an it's adding a new
paragraph um to the purchase and sale
that already has those other three
paragraphs for btim okay is is
that is that what uh the the
Realtors uh so you're it means a change
in the uh in the document in the pns
docu purchase and sale agreement
document or is it
just uh or is it something that's coming
from thees that you just hand the people
what I don't know I'm confused so you
want to know how the um information is
going to be transmitted right how is it
right
go we will take any answers you may have
sure so uh first I'll start with a thank
you and then I'll follow quickly with an
apology the thank you will be
representative Darby's been great
sharing the the draft language with us
over time my name is Adam Schmidt I do
represent the New Hampshire Association
of Realtors to date I've heard no
concerns about the language that he
shared with us so they're comfortable
with it I think representative renz and
this is where I'm going to tie into the
apology while I represent them I'm not a
practitioner okay so I can't get into
the the nitty-gritty of of how this
would work but it's my understanding
that anytime the language under this
particular section of law is changed the
form that representative Darby
referenced is changed to reflect any
amendments to this statute and I think
one of the things he included which I
believe we may have asked for is an
effective date of January 1st
2025 so that way it's not 60 days after
passage or something that's unclear so
we won't know when those forms need to
be changed it'll be very clear that
starting on that date moving for forward
the language which appears in the bill
would then have to appear on the forms
that representative Darby just
referenced I hope that's
helpful and and that's and that's you're
age you're in agreement with that I've
heard no concerns about the language
that's that um he has work to put
together on this amendment okay that's
fin thank you so
much further
questions from the committee
subcommittee
no thank you
please go ahead representative thank you
madam chair unless representative Darby
like to move his own Amendment I'm happy
to move this move the subcommittee
accept this amendment as written uh and
it's uh 2296 2023 2296
h
representative Darby I I'll second that
motion will the clerk call the
role would you like to speak to your
motion representative M sure U 30
seconds great work everybody I think
this is super good public policy was
very important at the time that we
recognized Arsenic and Lead was a very
important to notify consumers to get
tested and be knowledgeable this is
equally if not more important because
there's so many unknowns so like the
department said this will get people
where they need to go we'll
probably uh open you know shed a whole
new light on things and get a lot more
people educated which is great public
policy at least uh in the majority of
the state so
thanks representative McHugh um I want
to Echo that um support for the bill I
think this is really important it's a
notification that couldn't be more
timely and um we're waiting we're always
hurrying up and trying to do what we can
and then we wait for the EPA or wait for
things to line up so I'm glad we could
move forward I think this is Mak some
good impact and it also you know it
really it ask it tells people that we we
would like you to consult with Dees and
find out exactly what you're facing um
representative Ren Zulo those are very
good questions and I think that we want
to just always reassure people that they
don't have to do anything but here they
are with a problem and it's reality time
you know in order to try to
mitigate
the original uh subcommittee work
session form has everybody the entire
committee's name on it so I'm going to
just jump jump around to to whoever is
the vote the voting members uh
representative Healey yes sorry
yes
representative uh mchu yes
representative
Vale
yes and representative Darby
yes four to
nothing the motion passes passes for to
nothing that's
it it can I entertain a motion to
adjourn Next Step we now go we uh
the uh the the the commission or the
committee subcommittee uh this will be
this will BR brought into the uh uh
during uh our our uh
hearing final hearing the executive
session and uh it'll be presented as the
subcommittee's
recommendation motion to
adjourn any additional
comments questions before we close the
hearing I'm surprised it went as well as
it did I expected a whole kinds of
problem I mean
congratulations very congratulations
especially representative
Darby and Thomas and
Murphy
yep the meeting is adjourned thank
you